[H.L.] Gibt es einen Erdzwilling in der Milch-
straße? Wir haben 4 1/2 Tausend Planeten entdeckt
Mindestens. Wahrscheinlich gibt es noch viel viel
mehr, aber immerhin 4 1/2 Tausend kennen wir
und einige davon scheinen so ähnlich wie die Erde
zu sein. So groß, so schwer.
Aber jetzt gibt es sogar Daten über die innere
Zusammensetzung dieser Planeten und
die Erkenntnisse sind einigermaßen überraschend.
[INTRO]
1995, fast hätte ich gesagt Kohl war noch Kanzler,
seit dieser Zeit findet man extrasolare Planeten
in der Milchstraße.
Das war lange Zeit eine Riesenherausforderung.
Einen Planeten in der Nähe eines Sterns zu finden,
das ist ungefähr so als wolle man von München aus
bei einem Scheinwerfer eines PKWs in Frankfurt
ein Glühwürmchen auf dem Scheinwerfer beobachten.
So sind die Verhältnisse, weil die Sterne sind
natürlich wahnsinnig hell und die Planeten, die
strahlen zwar, gemäß ihrer Temperatur, sind aber
eben sehr klein und deswegen fast überhaupt nicht
zu entdecken. Wie kann man Planeten entdecken?
Die intuitiv einfachste Methode, die Transit-
methode, ist zugleich auch die erfolgreichste
bei der Entdeckung von Planeten. Also ob ein
Stern Begleiter hat, das lässt sich am leichtesten
dadurch rausfinden, wenn ein Begleiter an dem Stern
vorbeifliegt, dann senkt sich seine Helligkeit
Wenn dieser Begleiter regelmäßig vorbeifliegt,
senkt sich die Helligkeit auch regelmäßig.
Und daraus lässt sich eine ganze Menge ableiten.
Z.B. aus der Umlaufzeit eines Planeten um einen
Stern herum, lässt sich ausrechnen, über die sog.
Keplerischen Gesetze, in welchem Abstand der Planet
den Stern umkreist. Man weiß dann, wie weit er weg ist.
Wenn man jetzt anschaut, wie sehr sich die Hellig-
keit verändert in dem Abstand, in dem der Planet
sein muss, lässt sich ausrechnen, wie groß der
Planet ist.
Man kann mit einer anderen Methode, mit einer
spektroskopischen Methode, rausfinden, welche
Masse der Planet hat.
Wenn ein Planet einen Stern umkreist, bringt der
Planet den Stern ein bisschen in Bewegung.
Er fängt an zu wobbeln, weil der Stern und der
Planet um den gemeinsamen Masseschwerpunkt kreisen.
Wenn wir den Stern beobachten, dann sehen wir,
dass sich die Spektrallinien immer wieder verschieben.
Wir wissen: Bewegt sich etwas von uns weg,
verschiebt es sich ins Rote, bewegt es sich zu
uns hin, dann verschiebt es sich ins Blaue. Das
ist der Doppler-Effekt. Aus der Verschiebung der
Spektrallinien im Licht des Sterns zusammen mit dem
Abstand vom Planeten zum Stern, kann man die Masse
des Planeten berechnen, der den Stern zum Wobbeln
bringt.
Das heißt man hat Masse und Größe, dann findet man
auch die Dichte und wenn man die Dichte kennt,
dann weiß man, ist es ein Gasplanet oder ein
Felsenplanet und so sind Felsenplaneten entdeckt
worden, schon viele, und einige davon sind ca.
so groß wie unsere Erde.
Da wird man natürlich hellhörig: Das könnte genau
der Planet B sein, also der Erdzwilling.
Vielleicht gibt es doch um andere Sterne herum
Planeten wie unsere Erde.
Ein System davon, das besonders interessant ist,
ist Trappist-1. Da sind so viele Erden in diesem
System, da muss man sich schon sehr wundern.
Gucken wir uns das mal genauer an:
[Überleitung]
Trappist-1 ist nicht wie die Sonne. Es ist ein
Stern, aber er ist ein ultra kalter roter Zwerg.
Im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes, heißt, er ist ein
kleiner Stern, viel kleiner als die Sonne.
Weil er viel kleiner ist und weniger Masse hat, ist
er auch viel kühler.
Deswegen strahlt er nicht im Gelb-Grünen wie
die Sonne, sondern im Roten.
Vor allem im Infraroten. Das alles wovon ich jetzt
spreche,
das gesamte Planetensystem von Trappist-1,
befindet sich im Vergleich zu unserem
Sonnensystem, innerhalb der Merkurbahn. Ganz innen
drin, kompakt, aber dieses System hat
1,2,3,4,5,6,7 Planeten. Unglaublich. Das ist
doch unglaublich.
7 Planeten in einem Volumen, was so winzig ist.
Einige davon, z.B. Trappist-1 e, sind erdähnlich.
Ähnlich wie die Erde. Gesteinsplaneten. Machen wir
einen Steckbrief von diesem Planeten.
1. Er hat einen Erdradius von 0,93, fast so groß
wie die Erde.
2. Er ist bei 0,77 Erdmassen. Bisschen leichter,
aber doch nah genug dran und er hat eine Dichte,
die entspricht fast der mittleren Dichte der Erde
nämlich 0,96. D.h. wir müssen davon ausgehen,
dass dieser Planet ähnlich ist wie unserer. D.h.
er hat einen heißen Kern aus Eisen, einen Mantel
aus Silikaten oder eine basaltische oder granitische
Kruste, so wie bei uns auch.
Was soll es sonst sein? Was noch toller ist: wenn
man so Parameter von einem Stern kennt, dann kann man
sich z.B. fragen: Mit 0,96-facher mittlerer Dichte
und 0,77 Erdmassen, wenn er Wasser bekommen hat,
von außen, von Asteroiden, dann hat der Wasser.
Ist doch völlig klar. [Überleitung]
D.h. man macht Analogie-Schlüsse: Was wir über
die Entwicklung unseres Sonnensystems kennen,
das übertragen wir jetzt auf andere Planeten-
systeme.
Bei uns, im Sonnensystem geht man davon aus, dass
das Wasser, in Teilen von außen geliefert worden ist
Wenn es bei der Entstehung nicht schon in den
Brocken drin war. Das Wasser entsteht nicht auf
dem Planeten, sondern wird von außen geliefert.
Das könnte hier genauso sein.
Bei erdähnlichen Planeten wird es viele Brocken
gegeben haben und wenn in diesen Wasser war
werden sie auf die Planeten gestoßen sein und
dann könnten diese auch Wasser haben.
Das Wichtige ist: Dieser Planet mit 0,77 Erdmassen
kann auch Wasser halten.
Wenn er in der habitablen Zone ist. In der
bewohnbaren Zone um einen Stern.
Die bewohnbare Zone eines Sterns richtet sich nach
seiner Leuchtkraft. Ist die Leuchtkraft hoch,
ist die bewohnbare Zone weiter weg, wenn die
Leuchtkraft niedrig ist, ist sie näher dran.
Bewohnbare Zone ist die, in der der Temperatur-
bereich so ist, dass Wasser nicht in Dampf, in
gasförmiger Form und nicht in Eis da ist, sondern
flüssig. Das ist die bewohnbare, die grüne Zone,
die Wohnzone um einen Stern herum. Bei Trappist-1, ein
ultrakalter roter Zwerg, ist die bewohnbare Zone
näher dran. Trappist-1 e ist in der bewohnbaren
Zone. [Überleitung]
Was macht einen Planeten lebensfreundlich? Wir
haben eine Reihe von Planeten im Sonnensystem.
Auf dem einen oder anderen Planeten gibt es Leben.
Auf dem Merkur gibt es kein Leben.
Merkur ist so nah an der Sonne, da ist es zu heiß.
Venus, 450 Grad Oberflächentemperatur,
95 Atmosphärendruck, ist auch nix. Mars, gibt es
kein Leben, hat nur 10% Erdmasse, kann nix halten,
hat eine sehr dünne Kohlendioxidatmosphäre,
Temperaturen von -50 bis knapp über null.
Ist auch nicht wirklich. Dann gibts noch den am
wenigsten erdähnlichsten Planeten, die Erde.
Was macht unsere Erde lebensfreundlich? Gucken wir
uns die relevanten Faktoren an:
1. Sie hat den richtigen Stern, den g-Stern, der
im Grün-gelben vor allem strahlt.
Sie hat die richtigen Treibhausgase in der
Atmosphäre, nicht zu viel und nicht zu wenig.
Sie kühlt nicht total ab oder heizt sich auf. Sie
hat Wasser, ohne Wasser gibt's kein Leben.
Sie hat die richtige Rotation, 24 Stunden, die
verdankt sie dem Mond und die Erdachse ist leicht
gekippt, d.h. es gibt 4 Jahreszeiten, wichtige
Randbedingung für die Entwicklung von biologischer
Vielfalt und es gibt 2 Faktoren, die vergessen
werden, die zum Innern unseres Planeten gehören:
das Magnetfeld auf der einen Seite und zum anderen
der Vulkanismus. Das Magnetfeld sorgt dafür, dass
unsere Erde nicht von schnellen Teilchen getroffen
wird, wie z.B. bei Ausbrüchen der Sonne.
Für Trappist-1 e ist das ein wichtiger Punkt.
Er ist so nah an seinem Stern, wenn dieser
ausbricht und Trappist-1 e hat kein Magnetfeld,
wird die Oberfläche von der kosmischen Strahlung
des Sterns fast sterilisiert. Der andere Punkt ist
Vulkanismus.
Er hat dafür gesorgt, dass in verschiedenen Erd-
zeitaltern, wo die Erde stark vergletschert war,
sie immer wieder aufgetaut ist, weil aus dem
Inneren des Erdkörpers Treibhausgase rausgeströmt
sind, die die Atmosphäre treibhausaktiver gemacht
haben. Dadurch wurde es wärmer. Die Eisflächen
sind verschwunden und die Erde kam wieder in die
Warmzeiten. Das ist ein ganz wichtiger Punkt.
Wenn die Erde total vergletschert wäre, hätte die
Sonne sie bis heute nicht komplett auftauen können,
weil weiße Flächen Licht stark reflektieren und
die kühlende Wirkung verstärken. [Überleitung]
D.h. die innere Dynamik der Erde trägt dazu bei,
dass sie lebensfreundlich ist. In dem Zusammenhang
ist es interessant, zu fragen, ob erdähnliche
Planeten unter den extrasolaren Planeten
genauso aufgebaut sind wie die Erde, fester Kern, flüssiger
Kern, flüssiger Erdmantel, dann die Erdkruste, wo die
Konvektionsbewegungen im Inneren dafür sorgen,
dass die große Hitze nach außen transportiert wird.
Damit gibt es vulkanische Aktivität, die dafür
sorgt, dass die Treibhausgase an die Oberfläche
geraten und den Mechanismus, der das Magnetfeld
aufbaut. Diese heißen Gesteinsmassen sind voller
geladener transportierter Teilchen. Der Transport
entspricht geladenem Strom. Elektrische Ströme
induzieren Magnetfelder, ein Dynamo und ist auf
der Erde immer noch aktiv.
Wenn das bei Trappist-1 e genauso ist, könnte er ein
Magnetfeld, Treibhausgase, eine gute Temperatur,
Wasser und somit Leben haben. Doch wie ist die
innere Struktur von erdähnlichen Planeten?
Da gibt es jetzt neue Daten und eine Überraschung.
[Überleitung]
Bestehen Exoplaneten aus dem gleichen Gestein
wie die Erde?
Wie kann man das denn herausfinden?
Man ist froh, dass man Planeten um andere Sterne
entdeckt hat.
Wie kann man herausfinden, aus was Exoplaneten
bestehen?
Indem man sie kaputt macht. Wie macht man Planeten
kaputt?
Das erledigen Sterne selbst für uns. Sterne wie
die Sonne z.B. werden sich am Ende ihres Lebens
zu einem großen roten Riesen aufblähen. Die
Suzanna hat dazu ein Video gemacht.
Ob die Erde von der Sonne eines Tages verschluckt
wird. Was macht denn dann die Sonne, wenn sie
sich aufgebläht hat? Wenn die Energie nicht
ausreicht, stirbt sie als weißer Zwerg.
Die Sternleiche, die übrig bleibt von der Sonne,
ist ein weißer Zwerg.
Das ist kein Gasball mehr, sondern ein Material
wie ein Kristall, d.h. wenn auf die Oberfläche
dieser Sternleiche was drauffällt, bleibt es da
liegen.
Da die Sternleiche heiß ist und strahlt, würde man
die Reste von Planeten im Licht der Zwerge sehen.
Genau das war die Idee von ForscherInnen, die 23
weiße Zwerge im Abstand von ca. 4.000 Lichtjahren
von der Sonne angekuckt haben, ob sie Anzeichen
haben von Planeten, die sie aufgenommen haben.
Was misst man in den Spektren der weißen Zwerge?
Aus dem Licht der weißen Zwerge lässt sich die
relative Häufigkeit von schweren Elementen ablesen.
Zur Erinnerung: In dem Licht der Sterne gibt es
Emissionslinien und Absorbtionslinien.
Daraus lässt sich ableiten, welche chemischen
Elemente in der Atmospäre oder an der Oberfläche
des Sterns existieren. Ganz alte Geschichte.
Entdeckt im 19. Jhd. Wissen wir. So machen wir
Astrophysik. D.h. im Spektrum eines weißen Zwerges
lässt sich ablesen, was an seiner Oberfläche liegt.
Die relative Häufigkeit von wichtigen Elementen,
die z.B. die Kruste eines Planeten aufbauen:
Eisen, Magnesium, Silizium und Calcium.
Was hat man herausgefunden bei den 23 weißen
Zwergen? Eine unglaubliche Vielfalt.
Keine Anzeichen einer erdtypischen Kruste. Man hat
etwas anders entdeckt: merkwürdige, komische
Zusammensetzungen, die nichts mit dem zu tun haben,
was man von Felsenplaneten erwarten würde.
Die Überraschung war groß. Unter uns: Ich habe
das überhaupt nicht gewusst.
Dass man aus den Spektren von weißen Zwergen
ablesen kann, was die Vorläufersterne früher
mal in sich aufgenommen haben. Habe ich nicht ge-
wusst. Habe ich erfahren, als ich es gelesen habe.
Fand ich großartig. Bis mir klar wurde, ein weißer
Zwerg ist ein Kristall, wenn etwas drauffällt,
bleibt es einfach liegen auf dem Zeugs. Das ist
doch irre.
D.h. was immer diese weißen Zwerge aufgenommen
haben, es war anders als was man erwarten würde,
wenn ein erdähnlicher Planet von einem weißen
Zwerg, dessen Vorläufer ein roter Riese war,
aufgenommen worden wäre. Man muss sagen, diese
23 weißen Zwerge hatten eine andere relative
Häufigkeit als die meisten der vielen Sterne
innerhalb dieser Kugel von 4.000 Lichtjahren.
Das war was Besonderes und weist darauf hin,
dass es ganz anders ist bei den Exoplaneten
als wir uns das bis jetzt gedacht haben. Bisher
haben wir immer gedacht: Exoplaneten werden
so erdähnlich sein wie unsere Erde, wie z.B.
Trappist-1 e, auch erdähnlich aufgebaut sein.
Aber das muss nicht stimmen. Das kann ganz anders
sein. Man kann sagen bei 23 weißen Zwergen ist doch
viel zu wenig und alle, die sich auskennen in der
Literatur, wissen von Douglas Adam muss min. 42 sein.
In der Tat ist es so, dass diese Hinweise
zumindest die Bandbreite der Möglichkeiten
wie Exoplaneten aufgebaut sein könnten, wesentlich
vergrößert hat. [Überleitung]
Die Vielfalt unter den extrasolaren Planeten ist
viel größer als gedacht. Ist auf der einen Seite
schon eine Enttäuschung. Man hätte gedacht mit
diesem Verfahren würde man herausbringen, es
gibt so was wie einen Planeten b, wobei das Blöde
ist, der ist schon aufgefressen worden
von dem roten Riesen. Aber es zeigt sich, es ist
was ganz anderes. Es bleibt also spannend.
Mit anderen Worten: Unser Planet ist was
Besonderes. Einfach findet sich so was nicht mehr
in der Milchstraße. Das wird noch dauern.